-You're not on social medias.
-I'm not on social media,
no, I'm not.
-At all. That's a choice
or you just...?
-I just don't -- I can't --
I don't have the energy for it,
I think.
-Yeah. Never got into it?
-No, but I like the stuff --
Some of my friends will send me
stuff that makes me laugh,
and that's...
-Like a text or an e-mail.
-Yeah, something.
-So you can't really
get away from it all.
-I can't really
get away from it all, no.
But they'll send
some funny things.
Because they're all degenerates,
my friends.
-Yeah, exactly. I'm friends
with some of your friends.
-Yeah.
-I found something that I would
send to you
if you were on social media.
-Okay, show me.
-This is from "New York"
magazine, a great magazine.
It's "The Cut." It says...
"Sam Rockwell is...
Totally Kind of Hot?"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I like the...
-You like this?
-...the enthusiasm and then
the trepidation kind of.
-No, this is all --
-"Totally kind of."
-No, this is a full-on --
This is a great article for you.
"Sam Rockwell is
Totally Kind of Hot?"
-I'll take it.
I'll take "kind of."
-You want no question mark?
-No, I'll take it. Listen.
-You want an exclamation point.
-I'll take whatever I can get.
You know what I mean?
-I could see
the trepidation there, yeah.
It would bum me out.
-No, but "totally" is great.
And then "kind of" --
You know.
-But -- And the question mark
is a bummer, too.
[ Laughter ]
I was on a golf magazine once,
and it says,
"Jimmy Fallon Plays Golf?"
-And then
there's a question mark?
-A question mark.
-Golf?
You're like,
"Why wouldn't I play golf, man?"
-I'm on the cover
of this magazine!
You better play golf.
What am I there for?
-Listen.
It could be worse, you know?
-Yeah, I guess.
"Kind of Plays Golf?"
[ Laughter ]
Could it be worse?
Can we talk about
"The Bad Guys"?
-Yes, "Bad Guys."
-This is gonna be a giant movie
this week.
-Coming out soon.
This is a really fun movie.
And we spent a long time
doing it, and it's fun.
-The premise is great.
-It's really fun.
It's an Australian comic book.
-Yeah.
Where all the bad guys
get together and they go,
"Hey, what if we were good?"
-Yeah, they try to turn good.
-"What if we can be good?
And they --
It feels good to do good.
-Yeah.
-And let's see if we can do it."
And, well, we'll see
if they can do it or not.
-Yeah.
It's kind of like they're --
It's kind of like an
"Ocean's 11" for kids, I guess.
Or, like,
a "Reservoir Dogs" for kids.
-It is like a "Reservoir Dogs"
for kids, yeah.
It's really good.
You know, I love your dancing.
I always make you dance
every time you come on
even if you don't want to.
So I appreciate you doing it
and humoring me.
But in this movie,
your character, Mr. Wolf,
is actually a great dancer.
And you actually
got the director
to hire a choreographer?
-Yeah.
-For the cartoon?
-Well, they wanted to really
make it real, so they --
Unfortunately, Zazie and I
couldn't get together.
She was not -- just on a --
We were in different parts
of the world.
But they got Susie Misner, who
choreographed "Fosse/Verdon."
So she put it --
Susie put it together.
And she knows some of my moves,
and she --
We wanted to get together
with Zazie and Susie,
but we never had the time
and stuff, so...
-It's fantastic.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at "The Bad Guys."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-They stole the Golden Dolphin!
-Come on. You can't prove that.
[ Clang ]
-My baby!
-On your knees, bad guys,
with your hands up!
-Never! We're outta here!
♪♪
-So long, suckas!
-Well, this just got
a little weird.
-that's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, hey.
-Sam Rockwell, everybody!
"The Bad Guys"
hits theaters Friday!
And check out "American Buffalo"
when you can,
over at the
Circle in the Square Theatre.